el procedimiento de angioplastia
coronaria también se conoce como
intervención coronaria percutánea el
procedimiento se realiza en vasos
sanguíneos llamados arterias coronarias
estas arterias suministran oxígeno al
músculo cardíaco
el objetivo es restablecer el flujo
sanguíneo si una sustancia llamada placa
estrecha significativamente estos vasos
para comenzar el procedimiento el médico
adormece la piel de la muñeca se inserta
una aguja a través de la piel y dentro
de la arteria radial
a continuación se pasa un alambre guía
flexible a través de la aguja adentro de
la arteria luego la aguja se retira
se cambia por un tubo pequeño y flexible
llamado vaina esto permite el acceso a
la arteria
es posible que sienta presión cuando el
médico inserta la vaina pero no la
sentirá mientras se mueve dentro de la
arteria
a continuación el alambre guía se empuja
hacia el corazón
se pasa un tubo flexible llamado catéter
por encima del alambre para avanzar
hacia las arterias coronarias el
progreso del procedimiento se verifica
con un dispositivo de rayos x llamado
fluoroscopio en este momento el médico
retira el alambre guía y luego el médico
mueve la punta del catéter justo dentro
de la arteria coronaria para examinarla
se inyecta un tinte especial dentro de
la arteria esto le permite al médico
verla mejor con el fluoroscopio el tinte
hace resaltar cualquier obstrucción en
la arteria
si se encuentra un bloqueo significativo
el médico inserta un alambre guía en la
arteria
un globo en la punta del catéter se
mueve a lo largo del alambre hasta el
bloqueo
cuando el globo se infla expande la
arteria y mejora el flujo sanguíneo es
posible que sienta algo de molestia en
el pecho mientras esto sucede a
continuación el médico desinfla y quita
el globo
se puede colocar un tubo de malla de
alambre llamados stent en la zona
tratada el stent
ayuda a mantener la arteria coronaria
abierta su médico elige el stent del
tamaño adecuado que se comprime sobre un
globo
el stent se coloca dentro de la arteria
sobre la misma guía cuando el globo se
infla el stent se expande y se fija en
su lugar
después de retirar el catéter con el
globo el stent permanece en su lugar
para mantener la arteria abierta al
final del procedimiento la guía se quita
para obtener más información sobre la
angioplastia de arteria coronaria hablé
con su proveedor de atención médica